Koto c um I want to start off today by
talking a little bit about Minnesota the
Land of 10,000 lakes as the locals call
it
now Fair call I before about a week ago
hadn't actually been anywhere near
Minnesota um but in spite of that I do
actually know a few things about the
state I know that depending on which
sources you use there's actually
anywhere between 18 and 24,000 uniquely
registered water bodies across the state
I know that of those there are around
about 9,000 which have detailed
inspection data available for them
that's about 4 million Acres or so and
of those there's almost 10% of these
which are in infested with invasive
species which is a big problem for the
state and the people who enjoy those
Lakes maybe let's back up for a second
who is this guy why is this man from the
other side of the world standing here
talking about invasive species in
Minnesota does he realize he's not in
Minnesota right now these are fair
questions uh I'll start off my name is
Nick snelgrove I'm a tech lead at EP
interactive we're a full service
partners for Australia and New Zealand
with posit and the reason that I'm
standing here right now is because of
these four invasive species so for the
last four years or so we've been working
with collaborators at the University of
Minnesota the aquatic invasive species
Research Center battling these species
in particular so zebra muscle star Stone
W Eurasian water mil foil and spiny
water flea now when I say something like
battling invasive species you might be
tempted to think of something a bit more
dramatic it reminds me kind of of the
movie Jaws you know people out on the
boats hunting down these creatures and
bringing them to justice maybe it is
that way for some but uh in our case
it's a little bit more subtle the
creatures we are battling against are a
little bit smaller so we have to be a
little bit more
detailed so for me when I'm talking
about battling invasive species I'm
actually talking about how we're using
cloud-based infrastructure and a shiny
application called the AIS Explorer and
that's what we're going to go over today
so in this talk we're going to be going
over how we've built up this cloudbased
infrastructure around the AIS Explorer
to make sure that it's accessible to the
people who need it relevant for their
uses and that it performs well so that
they can focus on what they need to do
with
it so let's have a little bit of
background about this shiny app so this
was initially uh conceptualized back in
2019 with the support of the people at
the University of Minnesota and
specifically the Minnesota aquatic
invasive species Research Center we
wouldn't be able to do any of this
without the support of these people so
special call out thank you to Nick
Phelps Amy Kinsley and Alex badgers for
all their support over the years they've
been wonderful so the AIS Explorer
started its life as a decision support
and risk management tool to help
decision makers on the ground in the
county uh in the in the State uh protect
their Lakes from these invasive species
by linking up these complex analytics
with these practical decisions that they
need to make
day-to-day we finished development of
the first version of AIS Explorer back
in uh mid 2020 and it has remained in
production since then and it's been
actively in use
during that time so these decision
makers the county managers have been
using this app it's battle tested and
it's been through several updates over
that time we've continued to maintain it
and provide new features for the people
who are using
it there's some pretty complex stuff
going on behind the scenes here now I'm
not uh I'm not a data scientist my
background is in software so I probably
can't tell you a lot about the details
of these models but I can tell you that
we've linked up these kind of collection
of python and R models models into the
application so briefly we have a risk
model wristen in Python which uh is used
to determine the risk of lakes becoming
infested within the next 8 years I think
then we also have an intervention model
which allows users to kind of produce a
simulation of if they intervene at
certain lakes in certain ways so things
like uh inspections or decontamination
or education and Outreach how is that
going to change the story for these
Lakes we have an inspection model which
allows people to determine the most cost
effective or the most beneficial way
that they can place inspectors around
their lakes in a county and then finally
uh the collaboration model one of the
new additions which is enabling County
managers to see how the story changes if
they pull their resources
together so these models are pretty
complicated uh and that makes it a bit
of a challenging process to keep them
fed watered uh you know operating as
they need to uh the source data that
feeds these models uh updates pretty
frequently and the computations which
happen to produce the results we present
in the app are pretty intensive it takes
quite a long time we want to make sure
that our shiny app performs well for the
people who are using it so we need to
kind of address that in the way that
we're hosting this app and even if we
wanted to go with kind of a manual
update process that's not going to be
practical for us in this case either
because we don't actually when these
updates are going to need to be applied
it's a bit of a variable timing on that
one so this kind of boils down to three
challenges that we have which is how do
we ensure that the AIS Explorer is
accessible relevant and performant for
the people who are using it so that's
what we'll go over now we're going to
start off firstly with
accessibility this is how we're making
sure that these people can actually use
the shiny app that we've built and
prepared for them and the first question
we ask is where do we actually Host this
now there's usually a couple of options
between do we host it kind of on Prem on
some server that we have or do we host
it somewhere in the cloud for obvious
reasons it's probably not going to be
great if we host it back in our office
in Wellington so we decided to go with
some Cloud infrastructure and some
discussions with the folks at Mazar led
us to Amazon web services over 200
cloud-based services for us to choose
from 32 different regions 102
availability zones which means that we
can take our application and put it
right next door where it's going to be
nice and accessible for the folks in
Minnesota who need to use
it so now that we've decided on AWS that
leads us to the elastic compute cloud or
ec2 instances so these cloud-based
servers which we create one of these and
upload the code for our shiny
application into one of these instances
and from this we can do a lot of
different configurations if we need to
we can adjust the performance we can
change security groups uh we can
customize these instances however we
need to really we can also pick from a
variety of different performance tiers
so we can crank up the uh the
performance of the application by just
picking a different option from a drop
down and restarting the server which can
be really helpful because this app can
take quite a bit of effort sometimes the
other really useful thing about this is
that we get to record our backups and we
can take kind of a snapshot of the state
of these servers using the Amazon
machine images these Amis they're going
to come in handy later as
well so we have our shiny code on this
ec2 instance and then we actually need
to have some way of running the shiny
app and a little bit of a fun detol we
had to take with this one is that we
actually run the shiny app directly on
this ec2 instance now traditionally you
would probably go with a shiny server
but as I painfully found out while we
were kind of going through this initial
development there are some Ed edge cases
in here that come up when you try to
throw 18,000 Lakes onto a single leaflet
map which meant that shiny server
actually wasn't really having it for us
so we decided to just run the app
directly on the ec2 instance and that
brings up some questions which we'll
talk about later about how we deal with
multiple
users but with these Solutions we've
made our app accessible to the people in
Minnesota and they can use it and it
should be performing reasonably well the
next thing we need to think about is how
do we keep this relevant so we've got
these four complicated models in here
and like I said I'm not going to go too
much into the details of these models
but there's a couple of things to call
out here so if you have a look at the
kind of runtime of these different
models you can see it's a pretty
variable scale here we've got models
which take sort of anywhere from 1 to 5
minutes depending on the inputs up to 20
hours or more so it's a pretty variable
range of models and how long it takes
for these outputs to be produced
produced and all of these need to come
into our app at the same time the other
thing to call out here is that there's a
Common Thread running between these
models which is the source data which is
coming from the DNR infested waters list
so this is produced by the Minnesota
Department of Natural Resources and
basically this is feeding everything
else which we put into the AIS Explorer
all of our models depend on this Excel
file which lives on the DNR website so
we obviously need to know when this
changes and that's going to be the
trigger for us to actually run our
models again and produce the results
that we need specifically from that we
need two things we need the species that
that that a lake is infested with and we
need the do number it's a unique
identifier for each water body which is
infested in that list and I talked
earlier about kind of a variable update
scale uh timing and that's kind of down
to the season so when it's winter in
Minnesota the lak freeze over people
aren't really inspecting all that much
so they don't get a lot of new data in
this spreadsheet but during the summer
we might be seeing you know multiple
times a week updates to the spreadsheet
so we need to have an automated process
to know when that's changing and again
for that we turn to AWS so we're using
Lambda to write some serverless code
which will uh check the uh infested
waters list and see if there are any
changes from the last time we looked at
it and if there are no changes that's
great we don't need to worry if there
are changes though then we need to do
something and we're going to spin up a
processing instance to actually run
these models so we use a vent bridge to
kind of schedule that rule to run every
12 hours which is how I've ended up
having an email inbox which twice a day
gives me a notification has this uh file
changed yes or no which is great for my
mental well-being but that doesn't
matter so if there has been a change
then we spin up a processing instance
and this is how we are actually uh
running the model code and producing
these outputs that we need and it takes
a decent amount of time this is probably
running anywhere from sort of 36 to 48
Hours once we kick it off but we used
one of those uh uh Amis those images
which we created earlier to kind of take
a copy of a server which contains all of
our pre-processing code and we have a
Chon job on that instance that gets
created to Kickstart our pipeline
process that'll run through and then
when everything is completed we have uh
another script on there which will
upload all of our results so the RDS
files which are produced we upload all
of those to an S3 bucket and we'll have
them then sitting there uh waiting to be
ingested by the app so that all happens
without even need to needing to think
about it
really but then how do we get it into
the app that's the next important
question and the way that we do that
that is uh on our ec2 instance which is
hosting the shiny application we have a
chrome job which once a day will go to
our S3 bucket retrieve the latest data
that's available in there and then
restart the shiny application and we've
got this scheduled for about 5: in the
morning uh Minnesota time so that
hopefully nobody's going to be affected
when the server restarts and this means
that when people come to the application
all of the files that they need are
already available loaded directly from
uh from the same server that the
application is running on so they can
get right to what they need to
do that brings us around to kind of the
last point of this of these challenges
that we need to solve and that's the
idea of the performance of the
application we've already kind of spoken
to some of these points as we've gone
along so we've made sure that we're
hosting the shiny app in the right place
uh We've made sure to increase the specs
of our ec2 instance to uh make sure it
has kind of enough power behind it to
run maybe some of the more complicated
tasks that we need to do in the app
things like presenting all those Lakes
on on a leaflet map um we've
pre-processed our expensive model
outputs so that they're all kind of just
sitting there ready to go whenever
someone comes to the
application but the question then is
what else should we do and that kind of
comes back to the way that we're running
the shiny app as well so I mentioned
before that we're not using shiny server
on these instances because it was kind
of just a little bit too much in some
cases so that means that we kind of need
to handle the question of load balancing
ourselves uh so we want to make sure
that if there are multiple concurrent
users for the app that they're not going
to bump into each other and cause
problems uh in terms of their individual
user experiences and the way that we do
that again we're turning to to AWS and
we're using the load balancer along with
Target groups and autoscaling groups so
our load balancer is linked up to the
application URL so when someone arrives
intending to use the AIS Explorer
instead of just going directly to the
server which is running the application
they'll instead be directed to the load
balancer which we have in the AWS cloud
from there the load balancer is going to
take their uh connection and it's going
to redirect them into the Target Group
which has one of however many instances
we have of the AIS Explorer at the time
and so it's going to distribute that
traffic into the target group depending
on how it's currently being used and how
that load is currently shared across the
instances in that Target group in terms
of how many instances we have in that
Target group we use the autoscaling
group to kind of control that for us so
we have a minimum number of instances so
we always have at least at least one
running and then we have a certain
threshold which if the traffic on that
instance gets to a certain point then
we'll spin up a new instance
automatically so that as new people
arrive they will be redirected instead
of going onto the same instance they'll
end up on one of the new ones and it'll
kind of share that load out so that you
know people aren't really all crammed
into one specific
server and as it kind of automatically
creates these inst
as that traffic dies down it will also
safely tear those down without causing
any problems for people who may be using
the
app so besides the load balancing
there's one other thing which we want to
briefly consider which is around
performance tuning and we've already
done some of this we want to make sure
we're doing as little in the shiny app
as we can we've pre-processed our
expensive operations we cach our results
in the shiny app so using functions like
bind C in the app to kind of hold on to
expensive operations people may have
already done but the last question which
comes up for me is what if we need to
run one of our expensive models and for
that we actually went a little bit
outside of AWS um it kind of crosses
over a bit but we have on another ec2
instance we have open CPU installed and
we've taken our in this case the
intervention model and we've put that
into open CPU as a package which then
allows us to when someone is trying to
run one of these intervention mods
models instead of having them sitting
there waiting for 10 minutes while the
model runs and the report generates we
actually let them send this request and
then continue using the app while open
CPU in the background on a different
server is actually working on that
request and when it's done we email the
results as a report to the person who
was who initially made that request so
it's a very hands-off approach and that
allows people to use these expensive
models without needing to kind of sit
around and wait for the
results so using these cloud services
we've taken our shiny application and
we've made it accessible to the people
who need it most we have made sure that
it is relevant so it's always kept as up
toate as possible so that the decision
makers on the ground can make
well-informed decisions about the ways
that they're managing these species and
we've made sure that it performs well so
that you know people don't have to waste
time and wait around for the results
that they want to see they can focus
more on making informed decisions and
kind of taking that to battle these
invasive species we never really win the
fight against these invasive species we
just keep on fighting them and because
of these Services we've introduced the
AIS Explorer is and will remain a very
effective tool in the fight against
those species now and in the
future thank
you
[Applause]
thank you so much Nicholas um we have a
few questions uh I'll probably take a
few but if you have more um feel free to
ask Nicholas uh maybe outside after this
talk so the first question is do you use
an Amazon Ami or how do you get the
latest version of R onto your
ec2 so do we use the Amis is it correct
okay uh yes so we have these Amis set up
so we have one set up for the instance
which actually holds the shiny app and
then we also have one set up for the uh
instance which contains kind of our
processing code so there's kind of two
of those which we um are mainly using
and we have kind of other services that
we then use to uh get those going but
actually creating them is kind of a
manual process as we're going through
development so like whenever we do a
round of updates or uh you know we did
an update recently we introduced some
new models and as we were doing that we
uploaded some new code you know we
updated kind of the dependencies the
other packages we were using and kind of
just created a new image from that so
yeah as we're going through our
development process we actually use one
of those uh instances we have like a
development instance which we have
running just kind of in the background
uh and we kind of take that and then
we'll gradually switch that over to be
our new uh temp plate for the production
version does that make sense awesome
thank you so much um hopefully this is a
quick one uh before we move on could
your methods be generalized to work with
other Cloud
providers uh yeah I can't see why not I
personally am not super familiar with uh
I don't know I'm assuming things like
Azure um personally I'm not really
familiar with that but um I see no
reason why these couldn't be yeah
generalized for other Cloud providers
definitely awesome thank you so much one
more round of
[Applause]
applause